et on termine en tunisie ou en groupe de
10 militants du collectif citoyen contre
le coup d'état ont entamé une grève de
la faim opposé à ce qu'il qualifie de
putsch constitutionnel il souhaite
éveiller les consciences contre le
danger que représente selon eux la
politique du président accueille ces
aides notre correspondant à tunis ben
hassen chébili est parti à leur
rencontre garder
ancien qg de l'ancien président en exil
moncef marzouki cette maison juste
derrière moi en plein coeur d'el menzah
dans la banlieue résidentielle de tunis
abrite depuis quelques jours dix
militants du collectif citoyen contre le
coup d'état en grève de la faim médecins
psychologues professeurs ou encore
avocats tous s'opposent à la politique
du président ans sayyed et à ses mesures
exceptionnelles pour ces tunisiens qui
déclare être entrés en résistance cette
opération est le symbole de la lutte
contre une violation des acquis de la
révolution 2011 et un retour à la
dictature écouter
il est clair que nous sommes conscients
du danger auquel nous nous exposons mais
comme dans toute grève de la faim ou
actions de ce genre toutes nos
revendications ne seront pas entendus
mais je sais que nous pouvons obtenir
deux petites victoires ce message nous
ne la dre sont pas au président sayed
car pour nous et pour moi en particulier
je sais qu'ils n'écoutent que sa propre
personne
ce message est adressé à nos soutiens à
ceux qui défendent la démocratie pour
qu'ils se tiennent à nos côtés lutte
avec nous afin de faire front commun
aujourd'hui ce message est aussi adressé
aux partisans du président sayed qui
continue de lui faire confiance pour
leur dire regardez ce qu'il a dit le 25
juillet regarder ce qu'il a dit le 22
septembre et récemment le 13 décembre ou
va-t-il nous emmener il est clair que
nous allons tout droit vers une
dictature
on proteste haut et fort par cette grève
les les comportements qui n'aime la
police de ben ali n'a pas osé de le
faire donc il faut pousser ceux des
matches et on reconnaît qu'il y a dans
l'histoire de la démocratie plusieurs
difficultés on nous sommes conscients de
17,17 difficultés mais il ne faut jamais
céder il faut toujours aidé poussines le
processus démocratique
nous tentons par cette grève de la faim
de dévoiler au grand jour l'existence de
ce coup d'état nous souhaitons que cette
grève de la faim revêtent un caractère
politique et générale est que le pays
tout entier y soient sensibles pour
qu'enfin nous soient restitués nos
institutions confisqués durant notre
action beaucoup de gens nous ont apporté
leur soutien notamment un grand nombre
de partis politiques mais également des
membres de la société civile et des
défenseurs des libertés et de la
démocratie pour ses opposants les
récentes annonces du président de la
république notamment celle de la tenue
de prochaines élections législatives
dans un an le 17 décembre 2022 ne sont
qu'une façon pour le nouvel homme fort
de la tunisie de prolonger ses pleins
pouvoirs obtenus le jour de son coup de
force le 25 juillet dernier bien décidé
à ne rien lâcher ils ont annoncé une
manifestation nationale le 14 janvier
prochain une date symbolique en tunisie
puisque c'est ce jour 6 en 2011 que
l'ex-président zine abidine ben ali
quittait précipitamment le pays pour
jamais y revenir